foreign
hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear doing another shutter original
because I think I mentioned on the last
one that I'm kind of like getting behind
like on some of these shutter because
shutter keeps adding new stuff every
week and some of them look really good
and I just haven't had uh time to go
back and watch them so I am really
trying to watch some newer stuff that
they've added to shutter and this is one
of the ones they've recently added so
this movie was actually directed by a
guy named Duncan Birmingham who actually
I looked up his uh IMDb page and it said
that when he was in high school like he
got his started as a writer in high
school writing for the weekly world news
which if you're not from the US that's
like a type that's like several steps
below a tabloid it's just kind of like
you know it's kind of like chocoholic
mom gives birth to sugar-coated baby
type headlines like let's talk about
aliens and Bigfoot and stuff like that
so that's how we kind of got started
which I thought was like very funny and
he since went on to like write for other
TV shows I think he wrote for Marc
maron's TV show and made some short
films and stuff like that but this movie
right here this 2022 film this shutter
original is his feature film debut and
it's called who invited them uh so
overall I found this a very well paced
very decent uh psychological Thriller
but it has kind of like a large dollop
of black humor to it as well
um and even though the plot is really
nothing new it kind of Harkens back to
some other films in the sort of home
invasion kind of sub-genre I will say
it's a pretty entertaining way to spend
80 minutes like it's pretty brisk it's
pretty short and even though it's not
fantastic it's like I found it like you
know pretty entertaining and definitely
worth watching so here's the story
there's Adam and Margo uh who are played
by Ryan Hansen and Melissa Tang now both
of them looked familiar but then like
when I looked at their Wikipedia pages I
was like I don't know if I've seen
anything that either of these two were
in now Ryan Hansen I think was in that
Blum House uh Fantasy Island movie so
maybe I remember him that or when I
think he might have been in the Friday
the 13th remake so maybe I remember him
from that but Melissa Tang looked kind
of familiar too and I haven't really
seen anything that she was in so I'm not
really sure but she just looked familiar
to me so I must have seen her in
something else uh so yeah so they play
the main couple Adam and Margo so there
are these people and they've kind of
lucked into this great deal on a pretty
Swanky house in the Hollywood Hills
now right from the start uh the dynamic
between these two is pretty evident like
Adam particularly is a really insecure
kind of obnoxious try-hard type of guy
um and he's desperately trying to
impress not only the bigwigs at this
company that he's working for and
obviously like making a lot of money at
but also they're old friends like from
the old neighborhood and I kind of feel
like this is implied but he feels like
oh the old friends we used to hang out
with that's that lifestyle isn't good
enough for us anymore as we're like
moving up in the world and he really
really wants to be kind of like in the
glitterati I guess and he's just like
really really obnoxious about like going
about it and like I said it's like
really desperate and try hard so there's
that uh and then Margot his wife now we
later discover that she gave up I guess
something of a promising career as an
indie musician um I think they make a um
make a reference of when like her band
like opening for Beck or something like
that
um and she kind of gave all that up in
order to marry Adam and have his child
now yeah they have a son named Dylan who
looks like he's about five or six I
imagine we'll get back to him in a
little bit uh but Margot is kind of the
opposite she's very very uncomfortable
with this very showy display of wealth
she kind of liked it where she was like
she likes their old friends and their
old crowd and their old lifestyle and
she worries that the two of them are
just like over extending themselves in
order to kind of move in circles that
she never really particularly wanted to
be a part of in the first place so not
too long after they move in seems like
immediately after they move in and like
have everything set up Adam insists on
having this big housewarming party now
he invites mostly his work colleagues uh
but of course some of their old friends
from the old neighborhood uh come there
as well but they seem like they kind of
feel just as out of place as Margot does
like in this new environment and a lot
of them just kind of make excuses and
leave early so throughout the evening
Adam is being like cringingly
pretentious
um you know he's got like this big vinyl
collection he's very hipster and he's
just like curating it no one can touch
it but him and he has like this whole
plan and he also kind of makes this big
show of kind of plying everyone with
these really precious like Artisan
cocktails like oh I make the best
old-fashioned and he has to do
everything specific and everyone just
seems like they're rolling their eyes at
him because he's being so [ __ ] try
hard now Margot tries to hide in the
kitchen the whole time uh to avoid all
of this awkwardness and in general it
really does seem like nobody at the
party whether it's their old buddies or
their new work contacts appears to be
having all of that good a time and even
some of the people that that Adam wanted
to come like his boss and everything
like that like didn't even bother
showing up so the party ends at a pretty
reasonable hour because everyone's just
kind of like oh look at the time we have
like other better things to do you know
what I mean so there's that kind of
thing so before the end of the party
they have a friend uh named teeny and
her husband and they offer to take uh
Adam and Margo's son Dylan to have a
sleepover at their place like with their
kids because their kids are friends
um Dylan has actually not been adjusting
too well to the new house he's been
having like really bad nightmares and
wetting the bed and stuff like that and
the nightmares are usually about I mean
they only show it like once or twice but
the nightmares are about
um his parents getting murdered uh so
you just know this foreshadowing is
gonna come into play later on and uh you
know indeed it does now significantly
while the party was still in full swing
like before everyone left
Adam noticed this very good looking very
stylishly dressed couple that he didn't
recognize and they seemed like they knew
him or they belonged there because he
was like giving some kind of like
half-assed stupid speech and they were
over there going oh yeah you know what I
mean like they knew who he was and he
kept looking like who the [ __ ] are those
people so there's that uh so he was a
little disconcerted by this but he
figures oh well maybe Margo invited them
or they tagged along with one of our
other friends or something like that not
really that big a deal after everybody
leaves though uh Adam asks Margo about
them and she doesn't know who the [ __ ]
they are either
so they're like oh well that's was weird
so they just kind of chalked the whole
thing up to maybe it was just like a
misunderstanding so they kind of decided
to put this whole lame shindig behind
them and you know go to bed but just
then this weird couple that they saw
earlier pop out of a bathroom and scare
the Daylights out of them now it's
implied they actually kind of implied
it's like oh we popped into the bathroom
like to have sex that's what they were
implying um but then they lost track of
time and they're like oh did everybody
leave you know what I mean uh so they
apologize obviously
um but there's kind of like a wicked
gleam in their eyes I guess and when
Margot kind of gets justifiably mad and
is like who the hell are you and who
invited you
um they're like well you're gonna think
this is like really ghost of us but we
kind of invited ourselves uh they said
we're Tom and Sasha we're and they say
they're the neighbors they said
basically what happened was that we came
at our house and one of your guests was
like blocking our driveway and then we
looked over here and we saw that there
was a party going on so we thought oh
why the hell not we're gonna like pop
over there and see like what the new
neighbors are like so they decided to do
that uh they said oh you know we didn't
mean to cause any trouble or cause any
distress or anything we were just
curious and uh you know we're sorry if
we caused you any offense yada yada so
it seems at that point that the matter
has been and resolved you know everybody
kind of makes apologies and makes up and
everything and Margot is like okay bye
you know like kind of ready for them to
leave but Adam uh her clawed husband
wanting to I guess like seem cool in
front of these very obviously Rich
self-assured successful couple
um ask them to stay for a night cap over
Margo's very oblique objections she's
just kind of like no what are you you
know what I mean he's just kind of like
yeah you should totally stay a bubble
when she's like [ __ ] me so yeah so Tom
and Sasha obviously take Adam up on this
offer and over the next few hours uh the
four kind of drank you know do some
lines of coke we had various other
things and they kind of like get to know
one another
and as time goes on it becomes very
clear that Tom and Sasha are
manipulating the weaknesses of the other
couple kind of like turning them against
one another for perhaps some nefarious
purpose like for example Tom like
targets atoms sort of like upwardly
mobile self-importance that he has and
he's like oh I know all of these wealthy
CEOs
um in case you want to start your own
business they'd be willing to invest
like come play golf with me it's all
this other kind of stuff so he's like
trying to get him all these connections
because he knows that that's what he
wants
meanwhile in the other room Sasha is
commiserating with Margo's frustration
over having given up like all of her
artistic Ambitions to Hitch herself to
Adam's wagon and he's just like very
into material success and like showing
off in front of other people and you
know rubbing his success in their faces
and she's not really about that so she's
kind of like resentful that she had to
give her [ __ ] up so it's all like very
Insidious like how this other couple
kind of like targets them and knows what
their weaknesses are and what they can
like you know go after we also learned
part way through the movie that the
reason Adam was able to buy this house
for such a moderate price was because of
a horrific murder-suicide that occurred
there uh several years before like 15 to
20 years before and we further
discovered that Adam has kept this
information from his wife Margot which
kind of highlights another [ __ ] in the
armor of their relationship that Tom and
Sasha can exploit now I'm going to say
that I guess this it's not really a
spoiler because it's telegraphed pretty
clearly that Tom and Sasha were involved
in the former murder suicide somehow
um so I will say that while this movie
is actually really entertaining and I
had a good time with it um don't expect
it to be like super surprising because
the plot twists are pretty obvious like
early on you know that as soon as you
find out about the murder at the house
you're like oh well these two obviously
have something to do with it and indeed
they do like I said I don't even think
that's a spoiler because it's pretty
clear so as the situation at Adam and
Margo's house kind of Shades into
drunkenly boisterous dancing and being
all coked up and everything into like
some more Sinister threesome foursome
territory and then like you know them
not leaving like wanting to leave and
stuff while all that's going on there's
also kind of a small subplot involving
their francini who actually they left
the party early on like I said and you
know had their son like Dylan is staying
with them and she decides she's going to
drive back to adamargo's place to
retrieve Dylan's Pookie Dylan also has a
Pookie so do I in case you cases in case
it's your first time here uh I have a
cat named Pookie so uh yeah but the
Pookie in the movie is a stuffed monkey
that he can't sleep without and he's
just like I didn't buy Pokey because he
left it at home so but the kid at the
other people's house like is woken up
and he said he had a nightmare that the
you know that his parents have been
chopped up so I was like oh that's nice
teeny is like okay well I'll go back and
get his Pookie because otherwise he's
not gonna be able to go back to sleep
again and she can't really remember like
where the house was because like I said
they just moved here and you know so she
gets kind of lost and there's a bunch of
stuff going on with that I actually
really liked this little diversion this
kind of subplot here I just wish that it
had been fleshed out more and kind of
tied in more conclusively with the main
narrative but having said that
uh the very odd ending of this which I
won't spoil but I saw like a bunch of
people being like I didn't get the
ending but the ending I don't know if
I'd call it ambiguous but it's open to
interpretation like there's a couple
different theories that you could have
about it and because it ends that way I
have a theory about maybe what happened
like what really happened at the end
like to Adam and Margo and it if I'm
right about it then teeny's Side Story
actually makes a lot more sense like
ties in more closely I guess you know
what I mean so I don't want to like ding
it too much for that because if it was
what what they were going for then I was
like okay well that makes more sense
then if you've seen it you probably know
what I'm talking about
um but I think this is one of those
movies that I will probably need to see
it a second time because I want to kind
of confirm my suspicions about the
ending because I do have a particular
theory about it and I kind of want to
see if I'm correct or if I'm just like
pulling stuff out of my butt so all in
all like I said this was a very fun it
was just like a completely decent watch
like I said it's not very long I think
it's only like 80 minutes it's nothing
to write home about really but it's
pretty solid um you know it's just kind
of a Darkly comic home invasion style
Thriller I don't even know if I'd call
it a horror movie it's more like a
thriller uh it isn't particularly gory
or violent uh there is kind of some
blood you know when it gets a little
murdery in the third act like you know
when everything kind of comes to a head
but other than that it's not real you
know it's not real violent
um most of the tension in the movie
actually comes from the conversations
and like the interactions between the
two couples uh but I actually didn't
really mind that because I usually like
I said like psychological thrillers um
you know all the acting is good and
there's a lot going on beneath the
surface of like some of the stuff that
they say now I will say the character of
Adam in particular is uh an unlikable
douchebag uh but he's kind of supposed
to be that's kind of like a big
component of the story and as the movie
goes on you do actually start to feel a
little bit more charitable toward him
because he you know when he gets into
these bad situations and then you know
then you kind of start feeling bad for
him and he does actually seem to be
capable of realizing when he's being an
[ __ ] and like correcting his behavior
which is more than can be said for some
people so if you like dinner party
horror I guess where these sort of like
fraught social interactions are the
source of a lot of the suspense then you
probably enjoy this movie
um it isn't as good as some other
examples of kind of similar films like
uh the invitation the Karen kusama movie
from 2015 which is [ __ ] brilliant if
you haven't seen it I [ __ ] love that
movie
um or you know Michael hanneke's funny
games uh you know which he made the
original and the Remake
um or the 2013 movie Cheap Thrills it
kind of reminded me of that as well
which is also excellent if you haven't
seen that
um but I mean it's not as good as those
but it's pretty dependably absorbing
like it's a good psychological Thriller
with
you know some comedy to it and some
effective performances and it does
actually have like a really good sense
of like Dread and tension like
throughout the whole thing because
you're not entirely sure like you know
it kind of what's gonna happen but it's
like you're not sure like how it's gonna
play out so you know it is like really
good at maintaining tension in that
regard so that will do it for this
flickers of fear I will see you guys
again on the next one bye